parlons du VIH SIDA
entre 2000 45
il y avait un jeune qui travaillait
au port autonome de Conakry
sur le train de conducteur du train
mais à l'époque
les gens pouvaient faire
deux semaines de travail
un mois de maladie
et cela a duré un bon moment
sa maladie a impacté de son
travail un jour
ton chef direct
le chef de garde principale lui a appelé
il dit mon ami je t'appelle
pour qu'on puisse s'entraider
je vois en toi
que tu es un travailleur exemplaire
courageux ponctuel
mais vu ton état de santé
aujourd'hui je préfère que tu restes à
la maison pour suivre ton traitement
une belle proposition pour le jeûne une
belle décision pour le jeûne
le jeune à son tour
il a pas trouvé le contraire
le jeune s'est retiré de l'équipe
pour aller sur son traitement à la
maison
comme bien indiqué
son chef
le jeune a fait un mois deux mois sans
travailler
il suivait son traitement à la maison
le jeune il a compris qu'il commence à
recouvrir sa santé
un jour
le jeune s'est rendu au service
il s'est rendu au service
pour reprendre le service
son chef lui a vu
il l'a appelé au bureau
cette fois-ci
le chef était sur ses nerf
le chef était hors de lui-même
il a ouvert la porte grandement et la
fenêtre aussi
il a même coupé la climatisation dans le
bureau
il a mis une distance entre lui et le
jeune
il dit aux jeunes qu'est-ce que je
t'avais dit avec un temps sévère
le jeune dit quoi il dit non ne me
demande pas
je ne t'ai pas dit de rester à la maison
pour suivre ton traitement il dit oui
alors pourquoi tu es revenu
le chef du jeudi chef
comme j'ai retrouvé ma santé c'est
raison pour laquelle
je suis revenu
au travail il dit non tu es malade
le chef le jeune dit j'ai quelle maladie
il dit non ne me demande pas
le temps pour toi
lève-toi
le jeune repose encore la question
pour laquelle personne ne veut manger
avec toi aujourd'hui aucun avis ne veut
approcher ni boire avec toi
alors sors de mon bureau
le jeune est sorti du bureau
frustré
moralement abattu
le jeûne ne savait plus où donner la
tête ce jour-là
le chef ne s'est pas limité là
il a appelé un vigile il dit vigile
Verviers
a commencé à suivre l'instruction donnée
et il a commencé à pousser le jeûne le
jeune dit mais laissez-moi prendre au
moins mon sac
le chef est rentré au bureau
il a pris le sac comme ça comme une
seule été il a laissé il a jeté
par terre
le vigile a commencé à pousser le jeu
jusqu'à la porte il a mis le jaune
or
de la clôture
le jeune est arrêté
il a regardé son service comme ça
il a baissé la tête
il dit par cœur
le service
dont j'ai travaillé
pendant des années
c'est dans ce service
comme message aujourd'hui
de façon inhumaine
le jeune avait perdu le désespoir
le jeune est rentré à la maison avec le
cœur meurtri
moralement
psychologiquement hors de lui-même
il est allé rester chez lui désespéré
un jour
le jeune commence à suivre son destin
de la positivité
il y avait une émission à la télévision
une émission de la santé qui parlait le
VIH SIDA et surtout la prise en charge
gratuite
qui est assuré par le Médecin sans
Frontières
basé
au CMC matin et cette émission
a été une émission intéressante pour les
jeunes
il s'est servi de l'adresse
c'était
un jeudi
le 15 septembre
le vendredi le 16 septembre 2016 le
jeune s'est rendu au CMC matin pour
aller connaître la réalité de ce qui se
passe dans son corps
pour savoir
ce que le chef
l'a dit si c'est une réalité
le jeûne était sirop ignorant ils
connaissait rien du VIH
vendredi
le 16 septembre 2005
l'aventure de la positivité du jeune
commence
il est parti pour se faire dépister
il a trouvé une concert en place
il a expliqué son problème à la
conseillère
la concierge dit d'accord monsieur nous
travaillons dans un projet
du VIH
d'où le traitement est gratuit
la prise en charge est gratuite
également
il dit vous acceptez
le dépistage
on a deux résultats
un résultat qui indique que
tu es négatif
tu n'as pas de VIH
dans le corps
le deuxième résultat qui indique que
c'est positif
tu vis avec le VIH
la concert de vous acceptez
il n'y a pas de problème
la raison de ma présence c'est ça ils
l'ont dépisté
mais à l'époque
la science n'était pas là comme celle de
jour lui
quand dépister à l'époque il faut 24
heures pour le résultat
et aujourd'hui on te déteste
[Musique]
au moins de 15 minutes tu as ton
résultat
et à l'époque
je vous dis bien le jeûne est parti
là-bas à un vendredi
le 16 septembre 2005
le samedi 17 septembre pas de travail 18
dimanche pas de travail également
le 19 septembre
le jeune s'est rendu
pour son résultat il a trouvé la même
concert qu'il a prodigué un conseil
psychologique il dit Monsieur le
résultat est là
le résultat est sorti positif
il dit un bon
le résultat est positif
mon service a eu raison sur moi
mes amis ont eu raison sur moi
la conseillère a laissé
le jeune dégagé toutes ces émotions
dit qu'est-ce qu'il faut
il y a le traitement
[Applaudissements]
pour les paramètres
le jour même le jeûne a commencé
le traitement
un mois deux mois trois mois le jeune a
retrouvé sa santé il a commencé à
prendre le poids
un jour le jeune était chez lui
il suit toujours son destin
il y a un jeune de quartier
qui venait chez lui de façon habituelle
il dit aux jeunes il dit
moi qu'est-ce que tu veux me dire
on disait ici
dans le voisinage
que personne ne doit rentrer chez toi
parce que tu viens avec le VIH personne
ne doit prendre l'eau glacée dans ton
réfrigérateur parce que tu vis avec le
VIH mais aujourd'hui regardez
tu as retrouvé ta santé
le jeudi un bon c'est ce qu'ils peuvent
dire mes chers frères et sœurs
vous savez
qui était le jeûne
que vous demande
vous savez qui était le jeûne
c'était bien moi
moi qui suis présente devant vous
c'est comme ça je suis venu au monde du
VIH SIDA
mais il y a
y a l'ex-président de l'Afrique du Sud
le feu Nelson Mandela nous a enseigné
que le VS ne tue pas c'est le désespoir
qui tue
et le désespoir
qui draine la stigmatisation
et la cigmatisation aussi à son tour
draine la discrimination
aujourd'hui je vous exhorte tous ceux
qui sont là
d'aller vous faire dépister
c'est le seul moyen de connaître la
positivité et la négativité
et je vous apprends encore
mon chef qui m'a sachet au service
est décédé
j'ai eu la chance d'assister à son
enterrement et certaines de mes amis qui
m'ont stigmatisé
il y a eu la chance
d'assister à leur enterrement alors je
vous demande c'est ce qui les a tué
moi qui seul avec le VIH moi je suis en
vie
le VH n'est pas écrit sur le front de
quelqu'un
on peut vivre avec le VIH de 3 mois
jusqu'à 12 ans
le seul moyen pour connaître la
positivité et la négativité c'est le
dépistage
je vous demande d'aller vous faire
dépister merci merci
et merci
[Applaudissements]